Çeviri: Ecemnur Yavuz
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Bu videoda gördüğünüzde ben 2 yaşındaydım.
Aslında annem 7 aylık bana hamileyken
Amadeus filmine gitmiş ve
ben çıkmak istemişim karnından.
O da demiş
bu kız herhalde müzisyen olacak.
Ve o günden beri de
piyanoyla haşır neşirim çok.
O benim en yakın arkadaşım.
Aslında bu gördüğünüz videoda
çok önemli birkaç element var.
Birincisi çok mutluyum.
Gülüyorum, kahkaha atıyorum.
İkincisi küçücük diyorum.
Orada küçücük dediğim şey
aslında piyanonun sağ tarafında
yaşayan küçük yaratıklar.
Kuşlar olabilir
mesela küçük periler olabilir…
Piyanonun sol tarafında yaşayan da
korkunç şeyler var aslında.
Filler olabilir, dinozorlar olabilir.
Korkunç şeyler olabilir, yaratıklar.
Ve ben bunları hayal ederek
piyanoyu canlandırdım kafamda.
Yaratıcılık çok önemli sanatta
ve aslında her çocuk için de önemli
sanatçı olmasalar da.
Üçüncü şey de
orada bir ebeveyn var aslında.
Annem var.
Sanatçının gelişiminde mutlaka
anne baba ya da bir bireyin
çocuğun yanında olması gerekiyor.
Onu dinlemesi,
onu teşvik etmesi gerekiyor.
Çünkü öğretmenlerden daha bile önemlidir
onların rolü hayatımızda.
Ben küçüklükten işte 5 buçuk yaşına kadar
işte hep giderdim öğretmenlere
artık ders alabilir miyim lütfen diye.
Annem onlara sorardı.
Bakarlardı ellerime,
daha çok küçük elleri yapamaz.
Geri çevirirlerdi beni.
Ve bu 5 buçuk yaşına kadar
böyle devam etti.
Ve sonunda müjdeyi aldım.
Annemin bacağına sarıldım ve tamam artık
başlayabiliyoruz değil mi? diye sevindim.
Çünkü kabul ettiler sonunda beni.
Ve 6 ay boyunca
küçük parçalar üzerinde çalıştık.
Bunlar mesela Fil Yavrusu, Ana Cadde ya da
Peri Masalı gibi küçük yarımşar ya da
tek sayfalık eserlerdi.
Bunların bestecileri anonimdi bilmiyordum.
Ve bir tek bunların bize verilme nedeni
çocukların hayal gücünü geliştirmek ve
bizi mutlu etmek ve
paylaşma hissini vermekti.
Aynı zamanda tabii
inanılmaz büyük bir sorumluluk.
Birilerinin önünde böyle baştan sona
ezbere bir şey çalabilmek.
Çok heyecanlıydım her zaman.
Hâlâ da heyecanım devam eder,
sahne heyecanım. 6 ay sonra,
Türkiye’deki bir ulusal müzik ve
dans yarışmasına katıldım.
Ve orada şu parçayı çaldım.
Aslında şöyle anlatayım size.
Sahneye çıktım, 6 yaşındayım.
Ayakkabılarımı unutmuşum botlarla.
Kadife bir elbise ama.
Tam bir cartoon filmi gibi.
Kocaman bir kurdele takmışlar
bana böyle kırmızı.
Ondan sonra çıktım işte böyle
çok utangacım falan. Sonra spiker geldi.
Ne çalacaksın? Dedi. Ana Cadde dedim.
Ondan sonra, bestecisi kim? Bilmem.
Sayın seyirciler besteciyi bilmiyor falan.
Neyse, ama ben gerçekten bilmiyordum.
Tamam, o zaman işte
Ana Cadde sayın seyirciler dedi
ve ben başladım.
Yani yola çıktık arabayla gidiyoruz.
Ve bunlar da korna sesleri.
Böyle uyuşmayan seslere
biz dissonans diyoruz müzikte.
Şunun aksine.
Bunların aksine.
Bunlar daha farklı bir enerji yayarlar.
Ve burada da arabaların çıkardığı
bu sesleri taklit ediyor.
Bir tümsekten geçtik, durduk
ve devam ediyoruz.
Sonra güzel belki
bayırlar çıktı karşımıza.
Ve şehre geri gittik.
Böyle bitirdim, alkışlar falan.
Ondan sonra böyle çok eğlenceli bir parça
aslında bu Ana Cadde.
Sokak seslerini taklit eden ve
gerçekten hayal gücünü genişleten bir şey.
Çünkü bu piyano sadece
güzel melodilerin çıktığı
bir enstrüman değil.
Bizim hayatımızın her parçasını
gösterebilen bir ayna aslında.
Ve ben birinci oldum bu yarışmada.
Ödül olarak şimdi tabii bisiklet verdiler.
Hayat sigortası falan verdiler böyle işte.
Ondan sonra bir de
kocaman bir kutu sakız, çikolata ve şeker.
Bunu gördüm ben ve aileme haykırdım.
Zengin olduk!
Dedim ben piyanist olacağım kesin yani.
O gün karar verdim.
Bu benim kariyerim olacak.
Bir daha almadım öyle şeker ama neyse.
Böyle geçti ve çok, çok mutluydum.
Her sabah kahvaltı yapmadan hatta
diş fırçalamadan önce piyanoya otururdum.
Bir de böyle çok severdim
insanların bana adam muamelesi yapmasını.
Böyle çocuk gibi değil de
çok erişkin bir insanmışım,
bir bireymişim gibi.
Ondan sonra mesleğimi yapıyordum.
Mesleğim 6 yaşında başladı
öyle söyleyeyim.
Ondan sonra diğer bestecilere de bakarsak
aslında şeyler hep babaları
ya da anneleri ya da
bir birey onlara yardımcı olmuş.
Mozart da öyle, Beethoven da öyle,
Chopin de öyle.
Hep yanlarında birileri destek olmuşlar.
Ve ben aynı bu disiplinle
5 parça yapıyordum 1-2 yerine.
Ve sonunda bestecilere geçtim.
Ve aynı yarışmada 1 sene sonra
beni tekrar çağırdılar.
Bu sefer ödülü sen ver
yeni birinciye diye.
Ve şu eseri çaldım.
Böyle devam ediyor.
Bu bir Chopin Vals.
Ve bu bir yıl içinde, 6 ve 7 yaş arasında
inanılmaz bir gelişim gösterdim.
Ve bu aslında
sadece benim için geçerli değil,
bütün çocuklar için geçerli.
6 ve 7 yaş arasında,
onların beyinleri sünger gibi.
Her şeyi içine alıyor.
Çok önemli buradaki vaktimiz
çünkü sonradan okul araya giriyor.
Başka şeyler çıkıyor.
Aktiviteler, arkadaşlar,
sosyal yaşam falan.
Ödevler asıl.
Benim ödevlerimi annem yapardı ilkokulda.
Çünkü zamanım yoktu
ödevlerimi yapmaya.
Sınavlara tabi ben giriyordum ama
bütün o işte yazı şeyleri.
Ünite 1 aynı şeyleri yazdırırlar.
Paragraf, ilk baştaki cümle, ikinci cümle.
Yani neyse böyle testler verilirdi.
Onları sırtımda taşımak
aslında iyi değildi.
Tabii çünkü piyanistim.
Hatta bazen işte
sıra dayağı falan oluyordu.
Bunu anlatınca arkadaşlarım:
Ne? Sıra dayağı mı? falan.
Yani kültürümüz daha farklı tabii.
Ben devlet okuluna gidiyordum.
Ve çok farklıydı. Hocam çok iyiydi.
Bana az vururdu elime.
Piyanist olduğumu tembih etmişlerdi çünkü.
Ve böyle, böyle geçti.
Fakat bizim müzik öğretmenimiz yoktu.
Ve ben arkadaşlarımla
nasıl iletişim kuracağımı bilmiyordum.
Bir yandan yarışmalara gidiyorum,
bir yandan konserler veriyorum.
Ve arkadaşlarım ne çaldığımı bilmiyor.
Mozart kim? Bach kim? Beethoven kim?
Anneleri hatta anneanneleri, dedeleri
getiriyorlardı benim konserlerime zorla.
Kollarından çekip
ve bu benim için büyük bir sorundu.
Çünkü çok problem yaşadım.
Onlarla ne konuşacağımı bilmiyordum.
Yalnızdım.
Tek müzisyen bendim okuldaki.
Ve hatta yani
hiç başka bir arkadaşım yoktu
böyle ciddi konserler veren.
10 pardon şöyle 9 yaşındayken
ilk orkestrayla performansım, icram oldu.
Orada Bach Konçerto çaldım.
60 sayfalık bir eser, ezber. Daha önce de
sek sek oynuyordum provada falan.
Ondan sonra neyse herkes dedi
aa bu çocuk nasıl ezberledi bunları falan
ama yani çalışıyordum.
Çalışırsa herkes yapabilir.
Tabii tutku da çok önemli.
Eğlenmek önemli.
Zorla yapmamak bir şeyi.
Ve çocuklarınızı kesinlikle
yönlendirmeniz gerekiyor.
Neyi seviyorlar?
Ona zaman ayırmanız gerekiyor.
Ve her zaman, her eğitim sistemi,
herkes için geçerli olmayabilir.
Bazen özel şeylere yönelmeniz
onlar için çok daha avantajlı oluyor.
Ben ödevleri yapmadım ama
çok bir şey kaybettiğimi zannetmiyorum.
Çünkü üniversitede de
akademik hayatımda da devam ettim.
11 yaşındayken Kiev’de
çok büyük bir yarışmaya
katılmaya karar verdim.
Hayatta geçemezsin falan
herkes böyle şey yapıyor.
Hocalar falan. Ondan sonra ben orada
yeni bir öğretmenle çalışmaya başladım.
Rus ekolünden geliyor.
Ondan sonra beni hazırladı.
Fakat benim yanıma yollamadılar
öğretmenimi.
Ben 17 gün boyunca
4 elemeli olimpiyat gibi böyle
40 dakikalık resitaller veriyoruz.
Ve yani hani deha insanlarla yarışıyoruz.
Rus hepsi böyle şey inanılmaz çalışkan.
4 yaşından beri zaten
her şeyi başlamışlar öğrenmeye falan.
Ondan sonra bunlarla böyle
karşı karşıya yarıştık.
Ve finale kaldım.
Sonra cep telefonundan ders yaptık
Ankara’daki bu öğretmenimle.
Annemler tabii yanımdaydı. O çok önemli.
Ondan sonra ve bütün bunlar sonucuyla
artık hadi dediler. Yurtdışına gel.
İşte sana buradan ders verelim.
Festivallere katılmaya başladım.
Yaz festivallerine, okullara.
Fakat ben normal okulumu çok seviyordum,
arkadaşlarımı da. Burada devam ettim.
Ve sonunda, 17 yaşında
yurtdışına üniversiteye gittim.
Fakat kafamda hâlâ
bu sorular devam ediyordu.
Ben yaşıtlarıma nasıl hitap edebilirim?
Neden kimse
klasik müzik konserlerine gitmiyor?
Neden herkes bunun
sıkıcı olduğunu düşünüyor?
Muhteşem müzikler var.
Niye benim gibi kimse
bunun tecrübesini edinemiyor?
Ondan sonra
bu sorunlara ben üniversitede
ancak birazcık cevap bulmaya başladım.
Orada zorunlu olarak bir dersimiz vardı.
Herkes için müzik dersi.
Bu derste bizim oda müziği grubumuz var.
Bir tane keman, bir tane viyola
bir viyolonsel ve piyano.
Bunlarla biz mesela
Mozart Quintet çalıyoruz.
Hastanelere gidiyorduk,
kreşlere gidiyorduk.
Huzurevlerine gidiyorduk.
Her dönem onlara konser veriyorduk.
Bazen kostümlerle çalıyorduk.
Bazen melodilere karakterler ekliyorduk.
Biri cadı oluyordu, biri prenses,
biri prens, biri kral.
Çok eğleniyorlardı ve Mozart’ın mesela
yüzyıllarca önce yazdığı eserin
neden hâlâ önemli olduğunu
onlara anlatmaya çalışıyorduk bunlarla.
Bir yandan da piyanonun
bir zaman makinesi olduğunu keşfettim.
Bu aynen burada duran bir kitabı
açıyormuşum gibi
siz hani akşamları sıkıldığınızda
ya sıkılmadığınızda daha doğrusu.
Boş zamanınız olduğunda işten.
Böyle hani tamam bir gazete okuyayım
ya da dergi okuyayım falan diye açarsınız.
Ben de aynı şekilde notaları açıyorum.
Benim kütüphanemde notalar var.
Açıyorum bir sayfayı mesela.
Tamam, ne gelmiş? Bir tane Chopin, Vals.
Ya da birden diyorum ki of diyorum
keşke bir ay ışığı izlesem.
Keşke diyorum başka bir yere gitsem
burada hava çok sıcak mesela.
Bir ormanın içine gideyim.
Böyle bir gölde bir ay ışığı izleyeyim.
Ya da bir vals yapmak istiyorum.
Ya da bir köye gideceğim.
Bir çobanı izleyeceğim kaval çalmasını.
Ya da birileri vefat etmiş.
Çok üzülmüşüm. Yas tutuyorum.
Ya da 27 yaşındaki bir efsanevi
Beethoven’le tanışmak istiyorum.
Onunla görüşmek istiyorum.
Ben işte böyle kitapları açıp
başka yerlere gidebiliyorum.
Başka yüzyıllara gidebiliyorum.
Uzaya gidebiliyorum. Belki geçmişe,
geleceğe, her yere gidebiliyorum.
Bu benim zaman makinem.
En yakın arkadaşım.
Ve bunları ben insanlarla
paylaşmak istedim.
Yurtdışında eğitim sürecimde
Türkiye’de konserlerim oldu.
Ve sohbetli konserlere başladım.
Onlara neden bu eserlerin önemli olduğunu
anlatmaya başladım. Ve aynı zamanda da
yaşıtlarımın dinlediği müziklerle
nasıl birleştiririm diye
birkaç projem oldu. Master sırasında,
bu arada
Kraliyet Müzik Akademisi'ne gittim.
İşte çok tutucu falan.
Böyle işte klasikçi hepsi bunların.
Hayatta izin vermezler diye düşünüyorum.
Böyle rock jazz falan nedir onlar?
Öyle müzikler dinlenir mi falan.
Çünkü öyle öyle bir tavır vardır.
Bazı müzisyenlerde o ne?
Aşağılarlar falan.
Çok yanlış.
Müzik ırkçılığı diyorum ben buna.
Kesinlikle
uzak durmamız gereken bir terim.
Çünkü aynen bize de yapılıyor.
Klasikçi mi? Ah elit falan. İşte bu da
sofistike zannediyor kendini falan.
Neyse hiç öyle şeyler yok tabii.
Ve bunları ben aşmak için,
bu duvarları yıkmak için bir proje yaptım.
Hocama gittim.
Bakın dedim ya işte
ben lisede Pink Floyd çok dinlerdim falan.
Ondan sonra işte
birkaç düzenleme yaptım piyano için.
Ne dersiniz? Çalsam size falan.
Korka korka. Adam da böyle şey
25 yıldır oranın bölüm başkanı falan.
Böyle artık bütün en meşhur piyanistler
onun elinden geçmiş.
En meşhur yarışmalarda jüri üyesi.
Aa tabii dedi. Tabii gel dedi.
Çal bakalım falan.
Ondan sonra başladım ben çalmaya.
İşte burası gitar bölümü.
Çekil dedi.
Dur ben çalacağım dedi.
Neredeydi dedi o gitar parçası? Tamam.
Vokaller nerede giriyor? Falan.
Böyle inanılmaz.
İnanılmaz şekilde ben mutlu oldum orada.
Çünkü görüşü açık,
vizyonu olan insanlarla çalışmak
beni inanılmaz geliştirdi.
Ve herkese gerekiyor.
Her enstitüye gerekiyor böyle şeyler.
Açık görüşlü olmak gerekiyor, toleranslı.
Ve tutucu olmamak lazım.
Çünkü her müziğin,
her şeyin kalitelisi iyidir.
Ve ben master projem olarak
bu projeyi yaptım.
Ve sonra internete koydum falan.
Birden viral oldu.
Böylelikle bir sosyal medya şeyim oluştu.
İşte dinleyici kesimim.
Dünyanın her tarafından
tebrik mesajları falan geliyor.
Ondan sonra dedim ki yani
gözlerimden yaş geldi. Ve dedim
sonunda beni dinleyecek insanlar oluştu.
Oluşmaya başladı.
Ve benim için en önemli olay buydu.
Bir rock müzik grubu yüzünden
klasik müzik kariyerim başlamış oldu.
Daha doğrusu başlamış değil de
en azından insanlara ulaşmış oldu.
Çünkü ben aslında
6 yaşından beri yapıyorum ama.
Böyle. Şimdi size
oradan birkaç şey çalmadan önce
bir örnek göstermek istiyorum.
Klasik müzikte şöyle bir gelişme olmuş.
Girişimci besteciler varmış.
İşte Heiden zamanında
aristokrat ve kraliyet ailelerine
hizmet ediyormuş müzisyenler.
Sonra da Mozart gelmiş.
Ve Mozart tarihte ilk defa
bir kraliyet ailesine, aristokrasiye
çalışırken istifa eden
önemli besteci hâliyle tarihe geçmiş.
Adam çok meşhur ama
son birkaç yılı böyle sefil geçmiş.
Hem çok para harcamış.
Bir yandan da işsiz falan.
Sonra Beethoven dünyaya gelmiş.
Ve onun zamanında girişimcilik
çok daha farklı bir seviyeye ulaşmış.
Artık ona eşit bakıyormuş
aristokrasi aileleri. Onlara
arkadaş olarak bakıyorlarmış Beethoven’e.
Ve kime evet kime hayır diyeceğine,
kime eser yazacağına
kendi karar veriyormuş.
Parasını öyle kazanıyormuş.
Ve sonra Liszt gelmiş.
Liszt bir rockstar yani
hani bir rock yıldızı.
Ondan sonra ve adam artık konser verirken
karavanıyla falan
3.000 kişiye gidip konser veriyormuş işte.
Her kesime.
Salonlara gelecek parası olmayan insanlara
konser veriyormuş falan.
Ve böylelikle inanılmaz bir şey gelişmiş,
endüstri gelişmiş.
Ve ben de size küçük bir eser çalacağım.
Liszt’in Pink Floyd ile karışımı bir şey.
Benim bu master projemden bir parça.
Ve burada ben Dante’nin cehenneminin
burada piyanoda size tellerle,
efektlerle göstereceğim, betimleyeceğim.
Tıpkı ana caddedeki korna sesleri gibi.